jesse has just come out but
unfortunately Bungie opted not to
release a PC version of it just yet but
don't fret too much if you want to kill
a sci-fi shooter to play on your PC
while you pretend destiny doesn't exist
then you can consider some of these pics
you know while you mutter to yourself
about who wants to play an FPS on
console anyway I know you've probably
heard plenty about this one already but
if you like competitive shooters on new
and exciting planets then titanfall is a
solid PC pick it's all about the
fast-paced team-based multiplayer
element and the two games share a lot of
similar competitive modes like team
deathmatch capture the flag and whatever
they've decided to call the mode where
you control points the sci-fi element is
kicked up a notch with giant mechs jet
packs and smart guns that aim for you
among other sweet futuristic features it
doesn't have Destiny's class system
exactly but you can still outfit your
pilot with different weapons perks and
abilities and there are three different
types of Titans to pick from and
customize so while your Destiny's
playing buds are talking about whether
they picked warlocks hunters or
tightness you can tell them about your
own Titan a big people bearing metal
kind that is if you weren't all that
keen on the cooperative element of
destiny you may want to try your hand at
the story heavy and very cool dead space
the sci-fi and Space link is obvious and
although you'll be trading destinies for
main enemy alien races for a bunch of
Necromorph variants there's still plenty
threatening and dynamic the enemy
variety forces you to be flexible when
engaging in combat that is assuming
you'd like to come out on top in enemy
encounters and keep your insides inside
dead space forces you to be more clever
about your shooting for example head
shots won't cut it the game asks you to
dismember arms and legs with precision
to stop the baddies whose behavior can
change completely on a dime or they can
even spawn more or less than friendly
friends the enemies in this game are
terrifying so if you want to shoot
creepy space aliens dad's face is a
great
game-2 do that with as for a game that
emulates the single-player and co-op
campaign structure of destiny
Borderlands 2 is your best bet you've
got six different classes to choose from
and three different skill trees in each
to mix it up even further
there's drop-in co-op bird zillions of
different guns to loot and plenty of
different enemies to shoot boats destiny
and Borderlands are basically futuristic
first-person dungeon crawlers and you
can make the argument that Borderlands
could offer you more than destiny right
now thanks to its 9 major expansion
packs adding up to countless hours of
shooting space people in the face unless
you're totally hung up on a serious
shooter experience Borderlands offers an
awful lot of fun and silliness which is
super refreshing last up it's my
favorite combination of space class
focused gameplay and story awesomeness
out there you should probably play Mass
Effect again if you've never played it
before my Envy for you is off the charts
but even if you have this remains one of
the coolest sci-fi experiences in gaming
an entire galaxy is at your fingertips
with loads of different worlds to
explore to the beat of a killer
soundtrack Mass Effect is a cover based
shooter wrapped up in an RPG with an
awesome story about fighting for mankind
just like destiny sure there's some
frustrating Mako exploration bits and
cookie-cutter side quest maps in the
first game but it's excellent class
system feeds into its dynamic combat
that incorporate things like traditional
soldier eschew teenis 2 biotic space
magic powers to hacking robots and
making them do your bidding depending on
how many of those things you decided you
liked when it comes to sci-fi shooters
in space Mass Effect has more than
enough features to satisfy any destiny
cravings you might have also a romance
of a party members since that really
rounds off any sci-fi shooter experience
let me know in the comments if you have
any other suggestions for great sci-fi
shooters on PC
and let me know whether you prefer
saving mankind on PC or console I'll be
back next week but leave me your
thoughts until then